c'est quoi ce qui jette les gants la
ligue de hockey junior majeur du québec
pourrait devenir la première ligue de
hockey junior au pays à éliminer des
bagarres lors de ces matches pour aller
de l'avant avec cette mesure
douze des dix huit dirigeants d'equipe
devront se prononcer en faveur de
l'abolition certaines qui préfèrent le
statu quo explique ne pas vouloir
dénaturer le sport ou encore que
l'abandon des bagarres pourrait
entraîner l'augmentation des gestes
violents ou privées les joueurs d'une
préparation adéquate aux acquis
professionnels les arguments rejetés
parce qu'ils souhaitent élimination
totale de ces batailles mois de l'année
dernière année là j'ai aucun joueur des
remparts de québec qui continue au
niveau de la ligne nationale qu' une
expérience une expérience régulière au
niveau des combos la classe politique
abonde dans le même sens je pense que je
l'aï mentionné à plusieurs reprises ma
volonté de faire en sorte que les jeunes
évoluent dans un lieu saint et
évidemment ça passe par l'interdiction
ou la sanction des bagarres ont fait
affaire avec des jeunes joueurs mineurs
s'il ya des joints de jeu des jeunes
joie de 16 17 ans qui sont présents qui
tiraient dessus ce qu'on resserre on met
les quoi la taille plus sévère alors
qu'on accepte encore les bons vieux coup
de poing sur la gueule
les bagarres dans circuit courteau sont
déjà en forte diminution
cette saison on en dénombre trois fois
moins par match qu'il y a dix ans il ya
beaucoup moins de comptes de bagarres à
travers les années puis on n'a jamais
dit capable de dire clairement si on a
moins on pourrait tous les éliminer
complètement
on peut aller d'un côté ou de l'autre on
sait déjà quel est le jeu beaucoup moins
violemment valeur de de bataille puis
je trouve que ça vous intéresse selon
nos informations le vote s'annonce serré
et quelques voix pourrait faire pencher
la balance jeudi à l'issue de plusieurs
heures de discussion ici michael roy
radio canada montréal